freeze all motor functions let's try
again
[Music]
so much is real
is here advisable
this is the end
nothing else is in the way now
[Music]
we won't wear I can see the bottom you
woke me from a dream if I die you want
to see what I see there's only one
question left
tough will you help me
hey everybody it's Charlie this is going
to be my West world finale trailer
obviously last episode airing next week
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I love some of the dialogue in
that there's only one question left to
ask and that is can we ask like a
billion more questions the way they cut
this is obviously jumping all over the
timeline but for the most part there are
only two different timelines going on in
this trailer there's the end of the
two-week period because we have the
skarsgård brother that's playing the
dell o--'s character and we see bernhard
washed up on the beach like we saw him
at the beginning of the season all of
that stuff is happening after they go
into the forge so like all these hosts
here the big war that gets set off
because of clementines rogue code all
that happens before Bernhard washes up
on the beach and you see this nude ellos
person come in but there are a couple
really notable environments you probably
spotted so there's the actual physical
location of the forge you kind of see
the outside environment it gets flooded
with that water which also reminds you
of the end of the season oh my god I
killed them all with all those bodies
there that's probably a result of
Clementine with her rogue code because
like you see armistice here in Maeve's
squad just going crazy she screams run
because it looks like Clementine is
trying to use the horse to just spread
that code as fast as possible so they'll
all just erupt fighting each other
you also spot more of those anamorphic
scenes with the different aspect ratio
like the black bars on the top and the
bottom that indicates that they're
inside the realm of the forts at the
digital space like when Bernard went
into the cradle and met Ford for the
first time oh my god you've been alive
in here this whole time this is the
forges version of that remember they
said it was way bigger way more powerful
with way more people inside there it's
all the data they've been collecting
from all the guests this whole time this
30 year period that Dell owes has been
operating inside the park you also spot
more flashbacks to Bernard getting that
fidelity test from a version of Dolores
this also might be happening inside the
realm of the forge because anytime that
you see the anamorphic aspect ratio it's
usually them inside a digital space
instead of them being in the physical
realm when it's like a full sixteen by
nine frame so when you hear that voice
over from
llores and she says freeze all motor
functions let's try again that's the
same version of what was happening with
James Delos this is a test for fidelity
the freaky thing too is you see Bernard
walking through the hallways of the
forge you spot inside one of the labs
there's a body of James Della's just
sitting frozen like it's waiting for
them to implant another consciousness
you see a shot of a body being
constructed with Ford in the background
then what looks like Bernards hands
wrapped around a skull being fabricated
in a memory core now remember the black
memory cores are fir the hosts the red
ones are the human consciousness so this
looks like it's for another host there's
a really badass scene of Lee Sizemore
looking like he assembles the mave squad
to go rescue her much to their surprise
maybe saving herself with her crazy new
Jedi powers given to her by Ford he
unlocked core permissions so whatever
that is it just gives her a full-forward
level access to the park in all its
systems so she's as powerful as she's
ever going to get this is all happening
inside the Mesa still but you remember
this shot of the bull of charging this
person was actually way back in the
Superbowl trailer earlier this year so
they had footage from the finale in the
Superbowl trailer one of the other
really interesting things going on here
too is you see the man in black meet up
with Dolores and there's a bit of
dialogue where he says this is the end
nothing else is in the way now then
there's the voiceover from Dolores says
we will win inside the forge so
whatever's going on it looks like
they're slowly making their way to the
forge together at some point they find
each other in whatever is going on they
have it out because this is her crying
after Teddy obviously they pick up in
this moment here but the funny thing is
is the man in black still very
villainous even though he wants to
destroy the park he wants to destroy the
forge but Dolores has been the villain
this season so thick as thieves it's
funny to see where these characters have
ended up but it'll be interesting to see
how Dolores reacts to the man in black
because she sort of gave him up a long
time ago so I don't know that she loves
him anymore but they still have so much
history so it seems like they help each
other briefly but from the sound of it
Dolores wants to use the forge as a
weapon against humanity the man in black
wants to blow it up so she's probably
not on board with his plan but at some
point Bernhard winds up with Dolores
because when you see them looking at the
stacks here also anamorphic aspect ratio
it just seems like the forge is more of
a full-blown holodeck with anything that
the mind could imagine or might want
like this library is probably every book
that's ever been published because if
you're a digital person you have
immortality you have an infinite amount
of time to read all the books that have
ever been published so the other really
interesting thing that's going on in
this is you see what looks like an
emitter device and then like a beam
going up into the sky with a hole in the
ground
so whatever is happening here this might
be when they're trying to destroy the
forge in just the process of flooding
this area because remember mystery lake
is basically at the location of the
forge so when you see the water rising
around these bodies it just seems like
maybe there's cooling tanks underground
that keep whatever servers are running
but there's still a whole bunch of
scenes that we don't see in this trailer
because remember at a certain point the
del O's team gets their hands on Bernard
but that's after whatever he does here
after he scans himself into the forge
along with Dolores and you see them
walking around Sweetwater remember this
is all happening inside the digital
realm because she turns around and she
sees an older version of herself on a
loop but the other big question is is
what's going on with digital Logan
because we see Logan inside the world of
the forge and also even though she was
being kind of misleading Williams
daughter said that she wanted to get
information from her mother and find out
why she ended herself so that also
implies that their mother is in here
somewhere but also the funny thing too
is is you see a James del O's host
gunned down somewhat like he has scars
all over his face but you see him in
cowboy getup gunning down someone in the
street here so just expect them to go
full-on inception with the finale like
remember when they went down to the
third level of the big snow fortress and
it got really trippy just expect it to
be like that because when you're inside
the world of a matrix like situation
does all bets are off as to what's real
what you're perceiving the real question
is is who's going to wind up becoming a
host or getting stuck inside this
digital realm because they're inside the
room where James Dulles was cut that
little lost bunker
does the man in black wind up scanning
his mind in getting stuck in here and
who gets out like who evolves and makes
it to the next world the way the Deloris
the ghost nation who also appears during
the trailer had been talked
about because it looks like Bernard is
one of the few confirmed people to make
it out of this like he finally achieves
whatever level of consciousness Ford has
been trying to get him to do this season
the big question that they've been
asking this season several different
times is is what is real like what makes
a real person in Deloris has that voice
over in here when she's talking to this
version of Bernard trying to train him
for fidelity that which is real is
irreplaceable
and they also cut it with teddy like
Teddy was real for her because he's
irreplaceable to her so because that's
been the big question of season two what
is real we'll see if they have a
satisfactory answer but they've already
been confirmed for season three we might
not get it till 2020 though so I'll talk
about that when I post my finale video
but for all of you Westworld squad we
are getting new Game of Thrones next
year but we're also going to get new
Watchmen so what I'm expecting is is
that though err Game of Thrones season 8
starting in the spring early summer then
right after that they'll probably try to
pee back on that huge audience for the
finale and launch their Watchmen series
so Watchmen will probably premiere
sometimes towards the middle or the end
of next summer but I'll talk more about
Watchmen when they start dropping
footage so don't worry there'll be
plenty of that next year while you wait
for everything click here for more West
world videos and click here for brand
new ant-man and the wasp thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]